hey what's up my name's samuel leaves
welcome back to my property investment
youtube channel where i am going to be
answering right now your property
investment questions so if you have
anything that's holding you back in your
property investment journey let me know
and i will do my absolute best to help
you find a solution to your problem or
your question if you're having success
in property as a result of these videos
please let me know in the comments i'd
love to hear how you're getting on your
journey and i'd love to help you take
things to the next level so let's see
what questions we had last week and i'm
going to start answering last week's
questions and then while i'm answering
last week's questions
if a question comes into mind or an
offshoot to a question please do go
ahead comment below and the more you
comment and the more questions you have
the better content i'm going to be able
to give you next week on sunday so also
if you like my video press the like
button smash that like button make sure
that the blue thumb is up it's turned
blue smash the like button right now and
um hit your comments below so last week
we had somebody called zero zero eight
five sam he said
my question is
what is your view or general opinion on
people who try to build or grow a
property portfolio by purchasing on
residential mortgages
and using them for buy-to-let purposes
without telling the lender do you think
it hurts other investors or affects the
property market
so first thing i'll say is you can't
grow a portfolio this way because the
maximum of residential mortgages that
you can generally have is two so if you
buy a property and you tell your
mortgage lender that you're going to be
living in the property but then you
actually rent it out firstly that is
a breach of terms so you could be
penalized for that i mean in theory
the mortgage lender could ask for the
money back they could say hey you're
breaking the term can you please give me
the mortgage back and you'd be forced to
sell the house pay back the mortgage and
then they could blackmark you are you
going to go to prison for doing it no if
you've got a residential mortgage and
you've got a tenant in it should you be
losing sleep and
no but would i recommend doing that
absolutely i wouldn't recommend doing
that i understand what people do because
you're going to put down a very small
deposit and it's going to give you a
much higher return on investment but i
would really suggest that you get the
correct suitable mortgage and if i was
to say anything other than that i'd be
being a bad property advisor so
what's my opinion on it my opinion on it
is there's enough money in property
investment if you do it right to do it
properly
all right next ali baglam says
i want to get into property i'm 17 years
old i'm making 1
350 pounds per month through my job
what's your advice for the future
well if you're making 1
350 pounds a month
the first thing i'd say is you're
actually in a really good position
because i would rather be your mentor
than mentor somebody who's got a hundred
thousand pounds a year salary
but
they've got a wife and four kids and two
nice cars and a mortgage
and they need a hundred thousand pounds
to live
because
they're gonna need to create a hundred
thousand pounds
in property income
to cover their expenses
you're gonna need just over a thousand
pounds a month to cover your living
expenses so to replace your job for you
to become financially independent
is actually really really easy how would
i recommend doing it or for a start you
could rent an apartment
in your area
and then you could rent it out on airbnb
and booking.com and if you did that with
the correct contracts in place i mean
you're 17 years old so you might need to
do this um with with backing of somebody
but hey when i got started i was 17-2 i
got my first deal with 17. so you only
need to pull off one or two deals like
that where you don't even own the
property you just control them and you
can very comfortably replace your salary
so i think you're in a good place also
you've not probably got lots to lose
because you're only 17. i imagine that
you've not got
liabilities and big expenses over your
head so
i think the world is your oyster my
friend
danish iqbal says hi samuel i'm 17 years
old oh my goodness what is going on with
the 17 year olds great to have you on
the channel
i'm currently studying a levels which
take up my time however i want to become
a deal sourcer i've tried reaching out
to deal sources already regarding code
eagle sourcing but as i'm not compliant
however when they they ask me if i've
had had training or source deals before
i say no but when they realize they tend
to blank me what would you advise me to
do
so if you're looking to do codial
sourcing this is a very smart move this
is where you find deals and then you
just pass it to a deal sourcing company
and that deal sourcing company will sell
it for you they'll take care of the
contracts the investors the compliance
the selling the invoicing the terms and
conditions all that sort of stuff and
you'll get paid a percentage of that fee
um the reason they're asking you if
you've had training is probably because
they don't want you to bring them deals
and then the deals are rubbish
and they end up having to go that deal's
rubbish and you go why is it rubbish and
they go because blah blah blah blah and
they end up you become
a drain on their time and resources so
they want you to to be trained so that
you're finding great deals you've got
the knowledge you've got the experience
so that you're easy to deal with which
to be honest i think is
i understand why they do that
i mean you could offer to work for them
for free or maybe you could just get
trained and then you become more
valuable but i would do one or one or
the other make sure that you
become as valuable as you can and then
the money will follow
okay
um next question would the best approach
be a brr
if i was able to get a 50 to 60 000
pound house on a residential mortgage
living it for four to six months while
working on a refurb and then refinance
and then adjust the mortgage to buy to
let and get in some tenants
ibrahim i would probably say if you've
got 50 to 60 000 pounds
and you're looking to get into brr and
you're wanting to live in the house
rather than doing a brr
you might be better to do a flip
because if you're living in the house
and then you refurb it
rather than changing the mortgage why
not just sell the house
because if you live in it you won't buy
any capital gains tax which is going to
save you 28
so
if you're going to be living in the
property maybe take advantage of the tax
loophole and and and sell the property
might be an option maybe worth thinking
about
okay next lord raheem
i'm having an absolute nightmare with
title issues i've recently bought two
flats for 103 thousand i won them at
auction the auctioneer and sellers
solicitors are unable to tell me whether
they're under one or two titles
i was under the impression they're
separate before bidding i've already
paid 1 200 pounds for the admin fees as
well as paid 3 000 pounds which will
come off the purchase price i won the
pair of flats on the 31st of august
please help any advice is welcome
so
i mean first thing before i give you
advice is i just want to advise
everybody else
you said here that you assumed
that they were on two titles and the
lesson is never assume anything
because especially when you're auction
when you're auctioning you want to ask
before you bid you need to see the legal
pack and do you know what the most
important thing on the legal pack is
the most important thing you need to
look for on the legal pack is
the missing information okay so if
there's anything missing in the legal
pack or if there's any boxes that are
not ticked in that's the most serious so
that was a little bit of a schoolboy
error i'm not going to lie
however
what should you do now well if you've
already bidded presumably you've paid a
deposit or have to pay a deposit so
you probably have to go ahead i'm not
sure what the terms are of the auction
it might be that it's not a massive deal
could you get
could you get uh planning permission to
split the titles without knowing the
details of the house i really couldn't
say
however if you'd like to have a
mentoring call with either myself or one
of my team where we can talk to you we
can talk to you about the ins and outs
of the house then you can book a free
mentoring call on the house we're not on
the house it's a pound
for seven day
trial of our unlimited mentoring through
samuel 365. i'll leave the details below
in the link which you can check out
all right last question samuel i want to
start property investing and i'm
currently
17 years old
what is going on but i'm worried about
not knowing all of the laws contracts
etc like article four basically all the
legal terms okay so sam
you don't know the terms
so however you're not probably at 17
you're probably not going to be buying
the property what i would do if i was
you is i would find properties and pass
them to investors for a finder's fee
ask investors what they're looking for
find the deals pass them on and charge
for your time
you will be getting paid to learn
your refining deals if you've missed
something
the investor will tell you that you've
missed it you'll be getting paid to
learn that's the best thing that you can
do
i hope you guys enjoyed this video don't
forget to comment your questions below
and i look forward to seeing you guys
next time
you